[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar minnesota leads the nation in
congenital cmv building the case for
universal newborn screening
i am kayleigh bach of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by roche diagnostics
to learn more visit
diagnostics.roche.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr mark schleich department of
pediatrics university of minnesota
medical school minneapolis minnesota dr
schleich you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much and i want to thank
lab roots and roche diagnostics
i want to thank all of the members of
the audience as well for attending
this seminar
we will have plenty of time at the end
for questions
looking through the list it's quite an
eclectic group
of clinicians
public health officials
laboratory-based personnel so it should
be an interesting discussion
so i'm going to talk a little bit about
our program here at the university of
minnesota and how we've collaborated and
interacted with
the centers for disease control
and the minnesota department of health
in moving forward the concept of newborn
cmv screening
we'll touch briefly on the clinical
presentation of congenital cmv
and discuss why it's important
and we will also talk a little bit about
the studies that we've done over the
last few years
that have looked at
the prevalence of congenital cmv in
minnesota
then we'll move into how this
will
translate into a new initiative in
minnesota for universal cmv screening
through
passage of what's known as the vivian
act
the vivian act
will
enable universal screening in minnesota
sometime in 2023
so congenital cmv infection in
symptomatic cases
is quite an obvious illness to
clinicians and arguably
you wouldn't need a newborn screening
program to identify a sick baby with
this kind of appearance in the newborn
nursery
the petechiae purpura
large liver and spleen
often occurring in
concert with microcephaly
vision loss and most importantly
hearing loss
and so these cases are certainly quite
tragic
fortunately this is just a small
percentage of all cases of congenital
cmv
but these are the ones that capture
public attention
because of their dramatic clinical
presentation
in fact this is just the tip of the
iceberg
many babies with congenital cmv
are completely asymptomatic at birth and
actually have a good prognosis for
normal outcome and that complicates
the issue of universal congenital cmb
screening as i'll come back to in a
moment
we think that somewhere between 15 and
20 percent of all congenital infections
do lead to some sort of permanent injury
and most commonly that permanent
disability is related to sensory neural
hearing loss which may not be present at
birth
babies can
in fact pass their newborn hearing
screen
only to go on to develop hearing loss
later in childhood
risk for the baby appears to be greatest
if
a maternal infection during pregnancy is
the first seeing the infection of that
woman's lifetime
in other words a primary maternal
infection
and this gives hope to the idea that
vaccination could help
ameliorate if not prevent
some
if not most cases of congenital cmv and
i'll touch briefly on the state of the
art of vaccine development
but again for the purposes of this
webinar
we're left with the knowledge that the
majority of cases of congenital
cmv infection are in fact asymptomatic
and have a good prognosis for normal
outcome
so what is the basis of screening before
we get into details about cmv screening
we should draw a distinction between
universal screening that is to say all
babies born will be tested for cmv at
birth
and so-called targeted screening
which is an initiative that has been
taken up by many states
in targeted screening certain risk
factors will trigger testing of cmv in
the newborn nursery in some infants
most notably babies that refer on the
newborn hearing screen
babies that have unexplained premature
birth or intrauterine growth retardation
babies who are born to women who have a
history of an illness during pregnancy
compatible with acmv infection
universal screening again as the name
implies
is testing of all newborn babies one
area of uncertainty moving forward is
what's the proper test what's the best
test
and various publications and studies
have compared the value of testing
blood in the newborn most commonly
through the newborn dried blood spot
urine testing
which is probably the gold standard for
diagnosis but carries with it a great
financial burden because of the cost
of the time required to collect those
urine samples on all newborns
and saliva saliva certainly has some
theoretical advantages including ease of
obtaining the sample
but the issue with salivary
screening is false positive results in
babies particularly babies who are
breastfed
who aren't in c and b infected but may
have cmv dna in their saliva
another issue that has
complicated newborn screening for
congenital cmv is the lack of the
endorsement
of the newborn screening committee
that carries forth the recommended
uniform screening panel recommendations
the advisory committee's on heritable
disorders in newborns and children
the rasp is a list of disorders that the
secretary of the department of health
and human services recommends for states
to screen
as part of their state universal newborn
screening programs
disorders on the rest were chosen based
on the benefit
the ability of the states to screen
and the availability of effective
treatments
most states will screen for disorders
when recommended by
this committee
newer conditions
are less clear and may vary considerably
from state to state
so
at this time there is no recommendation
for inclusion of congenital cmv
screening on the recommended uniform
screening panel
there are efforts to nominate congenital
cmv screening
and these are being evaluated on an
ongoing basis
but at this time it does not appear as
though cmv will be added
in any short-term window of time
even though it continues to be much
discussed
by the advisory committee's on heritable
disorders
so should we include congenital cmv in
this panel
those who advocate for this say yes if a
baby's identified with congenital c and
b infection even if asymptomatic
that's a baby that can undergo a
diagnostic evaluation
and anticipatory monitoring for sequelae
most importantly hearing loss as i've
already mentioned
hearing loss may be delayed
in nature and it may be progressive in
nature
so
identifying these babies at birth may be
the only way
to discover hearing loss
in a timely enough fashion to offer
intervention
corrective intervention and therapeutic
intervention
advocates for universal screening
also point out that antiviral therapies
are available
and that these babies can undergo
serial neural neurodevelopmental
evaluation
that may improve their long-term outcome
on the other hand those that believe
that universal congenital cmv screening
is premature and not ready yet for
inclusion
will point out that most infants are
asymptomatic and have a completely
normal prognosis
and there's considerable discussion
currently about the overuse of
antivirals
as i'll come back to in a moment
the only demonstrated efficacy of
antiviral therapy in congenital cmv
is in babies that have significant
symptoms involving the central nervous
system
at the time of diagnosis in the neonatal
period
there's a considerable concern that
we're grossly overusing potentially
toxic antiviral drugs
and asymptomatic babies
or minimally symptomatic babies
with no direct benefit demonstrable by
any controlled clinical trial
i'll come back in a moment and talk in
more detail about the concern about
undue
parental anxiety that might be
engendered by a screening test
that mostly uncovers asymptomatic
children with a good
prognosis we'll talk a little bit about
the cost effectiveness or the perceived
or the
theoretical cost effectiveness of
congenital cmb screening
but this is an issue that's also
discussed in some detail not just the
cost of the screening test
but the cost of the concomitant
evaluations
that are undertaken when a positive test
is found including neuroimaging
audiology
and other laboratory
costs
it's been questioned whether or not
congenital cmv screening fits the rust
paradigm as defined
in the
basic tenets of universal
screening for
congenital disorders
the fact remains though that if cmv is
too bi be identified as a congenital
infection
timing of specimen acquisition is
critical
if a specimen is obtained from a neonate
beyond 21 days of age
then by definition we say that that
can't diagnose congenital cmv
in a baby that's been
breastfed or received colostrum
because cmv seropositive mothers
will invariably shed viral dna and virus
in their breast milk and so shedding of
cmv virus by the baby
in the urine or saliva
beyond 21 days of age may simply reflect
postnatal acquisition
as i've already alluded to there's also
uncertainty about the optimal test for
screening
whether this should be dried blood spots
very
advantageous
samples simply because they're obtained
on all babies as part of standard
neonatal care
but sensitivity issues have been a major
concern
urine and saliva as i've alluded to are
alternatives
but since this would require in both
instances collection of a whole new
sample
whereas the dried blood spots are
collected on all newborns in virtually
every state in the united states
this adds a lot
to the cost of newborn care and it may
be financially untenable
so what about the dried blood spot
the chimes studies of the early 2000s
referenced in this slide
raised the issue that the dried blood
spot pcr may be insufficiently sensitive
in the initial report of over 20 000
babies the range and sensitivity of the
dried blood spot
was only in the order of 28 to 34
percent
whereas saliva pcr demonstrated a high
sensitivity
of greater than 97 percent
these are the references that go along
with these papers
and so we set out a few years ago to
re-evaluate this issue in light of
improved dna recovery methodologies that
have been described since the original
chimes study
these consist of both improved
extraction buffers as well as increased
sensitivity
of dna extraction platforms
the hypothesis going into our study was
that the improved methodologies may
translate to a better sensitivity
of the dry blood spot pcr
than those studies that were reported 15
years ago
and that this might support
reconsideration of the dried blood spot
as a tool for universal screening so we
set out to compare the analytic
sensitivity of saliva and dried blood
spot for cmv detection
in a prospective unselected
population-based study in minnesota
so here's minnesota in red as you can
see for those unfamiliar with the
geography of the midwestern united
states
we border
ontario which interestingly is
the first province in
canada to undertake universal congenital
cmb screening
and we looked at these twin cities
nurseries
shown in the red
black arrows as well as an upstate
nursery in saint cloud minnesota
and obtained samples prior to hospital
discharge in the newborn nursery
following informed consent
that consisted of a saliva swab
as well as a consent to
punch
three
three millimeter punches
for each of our labs the minnesota
department of health
sent three of these punches to the
university of minnesota and three to the
centers for disease control so six
punches in total
the dried saliva swabs came to my lab at
the u of m
our lab uses a kai cube extraction
technique and a pcr assay based on the
ul83 gene
of human cytomegalovirus
whereas the cdc lab performed manual
extractions with a pcr for
ie1
and we simply asked what was the
comparative sensitivity
of our two labs how did this compare to
saliva pcr
and then what did we do with a positive
result
positive result triggered a report from
the minnesota department of health
newborn screening program to the primary
care physician
and so that was another aspect of this
study that i think was very important
the question of whether universal cmv
screening could be
inculcated into
the workflow
of the state newborn screening program
just as they would a positive screen for
hypothyroidism or galactosemia
these two are reported to primary care
practitioners who then arrange
for confirmatory testing and secondary
evaluation
the secondary evaluation was performed
using the criteria put together by this
international
consensus panel and published in the
lancet
a few years ago now
first and foremost a confirmatory urine
pcr
again aiming to collect it before 21
days of age
then a laboratory evaluation looking at
the cvc with special attention to the
platelet count an important biomarker
predicting risk in congenital cmv
liver function tests to look at
transaminitis
serologies
viral load by
conventional pcr
not research-based pcr with the dried
blood spot in this case but actual pcr
of infant blood
and then audiology and ophthalmology
referrals
neuroimaging was conducted by head
ultrasonography
these babies are currently being
followed up for long-term
neurodevelopmental as well as ideologic
issues
the lancet criteria breaks congenital
cme infection and disease into four
categories
moderate to severe symptomatic illness
mild illness
asymptomatic illness with isolated
hearing loss
and asymptomatic illness
and the only category for which
antiviral therapy
has been shown in any kind of controlled
setting to be useful is moderate to
severe illness
these were um our data
uh as um as of uh earlier this year
uh out of uh over 20 000 screens
uh an overall prevalence of congenital
cmv of about one in two hundred babies
you can see the maternal age breakdown
and in minnesota
we've
often been
characterized as
a population that's predominantly
caucasian but interestingly we found in
this study that
the race demographics of our screening
study were essentially identical to
those of the united states as a whole
with about 12.3 percent
african american or black participants
in the study
we then decided uh that we would move
forward with
diagnostic
comparisons of saliva
and dried blood spot
and this is this is what the data show
that when we compare the sensitivity
of the dried blood spots done both in
the minnesota lab in the cdc lab
we had an analytic sensitivity of about
86
uh this is strikingly better than
originally described in the chimes
studies of the early 2000s
when we look in greater detail at the
clinical sensitivity
this number goes up into the 95 percent
range in other words clinically
important congenital cmv that falls into
those two symptomatic risk categories or
the category of asymptomatic except for
hearing loss
yields an even better sensitivity
so this was reassuring information
that i think has
reflected in the field in another look
at dried blood spots as a tenable
alternative
for diagnosis of congenital cmv
when we looked at the demographics of
our cmv positive infants we found that
birth order had quite an influence
a p-value of 0.02 favoring second
pregnancies
or higher
and most of these babies with congenital
cmv in our cohort over the last five
years
have been born to
families where there is an older toddler
attending group daycare
we've looked more recently the at the
impact of the cobit pandemic
on the prevalence of congenital cmv
prior to the covet shutdowns that we all
experienced in early 2020
we'd screened just under 20 000 babies
with a prevalence of 0.45 percent
pre-pandemic
since the pandemic lockdowns we've seen
a striking decrease
in the total number of babies positive
for congenital cmv
with a post-pandemic prevalence of 0.15
percent
this in spite of the fact that the
collection of samples the research
methodologies the pcr testing
the technical aspects of the assays were
completely unchanged
so i think this teaches us something
about preventative strategies for
congenital cmv
namely
the idea that
isolating
hand washing hygienic precautions
uh the other notable aspect of the
pandemic lockdown was far fewer children
attending group day care
now data i
don't have to show you
today but that has become evident just
in the last few weeks
has shown that since we've opened up
again
we are now seeing a return to the
pre-pandemic prevalence and so i think
the pandemic has taught us something
interesting about cmv prevalence overall
pre pademic through the pandemic post
pandemic
still between
0.4 and 0.45
prevalence
pretty similar to what's been described
in other
studies in the united states
but again a major impact of the pandemic
what about the babies
we have found that most babies
as predicted are asymptomatic
a 17
fall into a symptomatic category
most of these are mildly symptomatic
infants
and 16 babies have been treated with
valgan cyclovir in this study cohort
this is publication from jama pediatrics
last year
showing the enhanced sensitivity of
dried blood spot testing for detection
of congenital cmv infection
i just wanted to share with you on the
saliva swab here on the left
you can see in dark blue all of the true
positives that is to say those tests
that ended up
being reflected in a baby with bona fide
congenital cmv
but in yellow the false positives we did
have some false positive pcrs
in babies that um ruled out for
congenital cmv
and when i say false positive i i
believe that there was cmv dna present
we were able to trace a handful of these
positive results to a specific nursery
in our study nursery cohort
where donor milk is commonly utilized
uh suggesting that that may have been a
source for cmv dna
on co in contrast though we only saw one
false positive dried blood spot in a
baby that ruled out for congenital cmb
so i think as the field moves forward
this is going to continue to be
an open point for discussion
the role of saliva testing there are a
number of
clinically marketed
saliva based testing methodologies that
are currently either available or in
development or deployment
and how these will be incorporated into
targeted or universal cmv screening
programs remains to be determined
so does cmv fit the paradigm of newborn
screening
the newborn screening story
begins with one simple test
and that's the test for phenylketonuria
and here's the
slide demonstrating the
autosomal recessive segregation of the
pku gene
that leads to
abnormalities in the metabolism of
phenylalanine
pku
testing which was developed by dr bob
guthrie who's been named the father of
newborn screening in some publications
is an area of interest a personal
interest for me simply because bob
guthrie attended the university of
minnesota where i'm on the faculty
and he of course was driven by a number
of family members with pku
it's interesting looking back at the
papers
of the day
when this test was moving forward to the
clinic
and the strong pushback that existed
from organized to medical groups
including the ama as well as other
editorials from thought leaders
who were very opposed to
incorporation of newborn screening for
pku
into clinical practice
the argument was that pku's screening
again some of the same arguments we hear
with cmv
may generate false anxiety
and
lead to
unnecessary concern moreover there were
comments in some of the editorials of
the time
that the test had not been shown to be
cost effective and had not been properly
validated again
some of the criticisms we hear about cmv
testing
pku testing of course is drawn on the
dried blood spot
and the principles and practice for
screening of disease articulated by
wilson and junger in 1968
are still used today when discussing
whether we should add cmv testing to the
universal newborn screening portfolio
is it an important condition is there a
treatment available
are there facilities for diagnosis and
treatment is it a diagnosis that's
difficult to recognize early
certainly is true of cmv
is the screening test suitable again
that's argued with cmv especially with
the dried blood spot
which although i think has an enhanced
sensitivity compared to the chime
studies of the early 2000s still is not
a perfect test
and what do we know about the natural
history
the vulnerable child syndrome has been
articulated as a concern for universal
congenital cmb screening
and this paper by givers at all
actually called into question the ethics
of targeted and universal congenital cmv
screening
because of concern that it might create
undue anxiety for parents
i think these kinds of arguments and
positions
are extremely important and need to be
discussed
but we also need to balance this with
concerns about
excessive paternalism in clinical
practice
the idea that we may have a test
available but that parents should not be
empowered
with having the information because as
doctors we know best we know this is
really nothing to worry about
we don't want to create undue anxiety
in fact if we go through the wilson and
junger checklist
i think cmv
checks all the boxes
it's something that we can treat and
bear in mind that
treatment of
disorders in
clinical practice is so much more than
just writing a prescription for
medication
treatment is audiology it's anticipatory
guidance it's monitoring these babies
development
we do have facilities for follow-up
long-term disabilities are incompletely
defined
but there is a recognizable latent phase
in these babies who may not declare with
their hearing loss or developmental
delay until later in childhood
we are i think now at the
poised at the point of having a suitable
test for examination using dried blood
spots
should be accessible to acceptable to
the population
and parent groups again and again
have endorsed and supported the idea of
cmv testing even if they know that the
outcome may be uncertain in some cases
outcomes vary with congenital cmv
but we all agree
that monitoring is essential
a policy
for congenital cmv
testing screening and treatment
is something that continues to be much
discussed and i hope to see the rasp
take this on in future iterations
but cost effectiveness of cmv screening
has been supported by modeling studies
universal cmv screening has been in
place in ontario canada for a couple of
years
and the test i think is sufficiently
sensitive
to warrant adoption into clinical
practice
this is an important paper in jama
pediatrics by soren gant and colleagues
i'll call to your attention
that does analyze the benefits of cmv
screening
based on not only the anticipated
benefit of antiviral therapy in affected
babies
to reduce hearing loss and improve
developmental outcome but also the
benefits of earlier identification of
hearing loss
and congenital cmv screening is very
much tied in with the eddy mandate
of
early detection and intervention to
improve
hearing speech and language outcomes
and it's not surprising that in ontario
it was really
the eddie program that adopted cmv
screening before the
newborn screening panel in the health
department
this is also data and there are several
studies similar to this one that
in surveying caregivers
families
uh the vast majority would want to know
if their baby had congenital cmv
even if it never caused any problem for
that baby in the future
and so i think these kinds of
focus group analyses
are extremely important
the initial positive newborn blood spot
results could cause some stress and
anxiety but most parents still
overwhelmingly support
routine newborn screening for congenital
cmv
the other point i would make is that the
wilson and junger criteria
are being re-thought in the post-genomic
age
when wilson and junger published their
algorithm for newborn screening for
heritable disorders
over 50 years ago now
they never could have anticipated
the availability of a whole exome
sequence on a young baby in a matter of
days or even hours at a reasonable cost
the idea that in the genomic age
these criteria
might not hold up i think is important
many of them are fundamental and
important
but we need to expand on them and we
need to recognize that in an era
of sequence analysis and advanced
genetic analysis of
pediatric health
that the wilson and junior criteria may
need to be revisited
and then lastly i would make the point
that
health equity and access is is really a
critical issue and one that i think
needs to be
more
regularly discussed
it's one thing to market
general cmv's testing kits
that might be done electively for those
who have resources and the availability
to pay
um but i believe that health equity
and uniform access is critical
we need to make sure that all babies are
tested if we're going to undertake
testing
recognizing that congenital cmv is very
much a disease of health disparities
that disproportionately targets
black and african-american babies
so we need to keep this in mind and
that's why i believe state health
departments
should be taking the lead to ensure
equity
well ultimately the prevention of
congenital cmv could depend upon
licensure of a successful vaccine
and i just wanted to spend a couple of
minutes to update this audience on some
developments in this space
cmv vaccine research began all the way
back in the 1970s
and there have been
a number of studies that have shown
varying degrees of
immunogenicity
and
[Music]
in one study
a modest success against acquisition of
infection
but not successful enough to merit
licensure and so none have been
successful
if success is defined as bringing a
product
into the clinic for for licensed use
this is surprising in light of the fact
that the academy of medicine in the
early part of this millennium identified
a c b vaccine
as the highest level level one priority
for new vaccine development in the
united states
we have seen progress in recent years
we've seen
evaluation of mrna-based platforms in
phase one and phase two studies and now
in a phase three study
we've seen protein subunit vaccines in
pre-clinical and phase 1 study
but there's no license cmb vaccine
available yet
just to review this
complex virus this cartoon shows the cmv
particle
it's the largest human virus both in
terms of size of the very virion the
virus particle
as well as in the number of encoded gene
products
over 200 open reading frames defined in
the late 1990s by dna sequence analysis
and now
with
splice variants and alternative
codon usage patterns
it appears that there may be as many as
800 unique open reading frames encoded
by cmv
of all of these open reading frames the
ones shown in the cartoons as the
envelope glycoproteins including the
glycoprotein b
and the so-called panamera complex are
the leading candidates
for
phase three study currently
there are also proteins in the layer
between the viral envelope and the
nucleocapsid known as the tegument
in particular one known as pp65
that is in several cmv vaccine
candidates and a non-structural protein
the so-called ie1 gene
these are the various platforms that
have gone into the clinic or are
approaching
human clinical trials
these include virus-like particles
vectored vaccines in which the cmv genes
are expressed in a
another heterologous viral vector
somewhat similar to one of the covet
vaccines licensed in the united states
there are nucleic acid-based
technologies and again by analogy with
covet 19
mrna based vaccines
with cmv gene products
live attenuated vaccines or disabled
vaccines disc
an acronym for disabled infectious
single cycle
meaning the virus can get in express its
gene products
but it has a genetically programmed dead
end it can't replicate and make
replication competent virus
and then what we would now call i guess
old-fashioned vaccines based on protein
subunits mixed with adjuvants
and one of these vaccines the gb subunit
ad mixed with mf59 adjuvant
an adjuvant that's now approved for
human use in a flu vaccine
did show about a 50 efficacy
in young women
against acquisition of a primary cmv
infection
finally peptide-based vaccines which may
be more
useful ultimately for control of cmv
disease in transplant patients rather
than pregnant women
these are a couple of current studies
one a
attenuated disc virus
the v160 vaccine
and then an mrna-based vaccine
which codes cmv gene products
that
are
inclusive of the geb
and panamer or panameric complex that i
mentioned a moment ago
well just to finish up we'll talk now
about what's going on in minnesota
and this effort started
a few years ago about the same time we
were starting our collaborative dried
blood spot screening study
in collaboration with the minnesota
department of health and the centers for
disease control
this was a completely separate
initiative undertaken actually by
parent groups
including
the mother of one of my patients
a woman named leah henriksen her
daughter vivian had symptomatic
congenital cmv infection
and so we talked in 2016
about how it would really be
useful to
approach our legislative representatives
in saint paul
to explore the possibility of a
cmv bill initially
hoping that we would in minnesota like
many states
be able to procure funding from the
legislature to
hire an individual who could
improve knowledge education and
awareness of cmv
knowledge education and awareness of cmv
have been a big problem
you can see on the left the total number
of infectious causes of neurologic
damage in infancy
and cmv
is more significant than congenital
rubella or hemophilus influenzae
meningitis
diseases that have now been largely
solved by vaccination
and yet when we look at knowledge and
awareness of the condition among women
cmv even though it's more common than
all of these other infections and
diseases fetal alcohol syndrome spina
bifida
sids down syndrome hiv
almost all women know about these
diagnoses but if you add them all up
it's fewer cases of damaged babies every
year than cmv which is the least well
recognized
so we were hopeful that we could pass
legislation
that would increase knowledge and
awareness of cmv
well the years went by and we
had some progress with the bill
we were able to get it to the governor's
desk in 2018 but it was unfortunately
vetoed
as part of a larger omnibus veto
and yet the parent groups kept
increasing
other
parent advocates including steph steidel
and her son hank identified by our
universal screen screening study
stepped up and
redoubled their efforts to try to
get
the legislators to recognize and talk
about this
after
uh several years and several
efforts we really began to make headway
in 2021
at committee meetings hearings
discussions
and we managed to make it all the way
to passage
and so the vivian act was included in
the senate health and human services
budget
at this point we decided to go for broke
and not just include
knowledge and awareness but also
universal screening
and senator karen housley
was the leader but had many many
co-sponsors on the bill both in the
senate
as well as in the house of
representatives
that got this bill to the finish line
one of the hallmarks of the bill was
that once passed
it had to be approved by the
minnesota commissioner of health
who sent it back to the newborn
screening panel
for a series of meetings and discussions
in the fall some evidence-based analyses
and after these hearings and sessions
a vote was taken not a binding vote but
a vote to support the measure and it did
pass
overwhelmingly
and went back to the minnesota health
commissioner's desk in
february
who then signed off on the on the
legislation
so
over the last few months
the minnesota department of health has
been working on
trying to
develop
a plan
and the rollout hopefully will be to
begin a universal screening program in
2023
as a part of the legislation funds were
allocated to pay for the testing as well
as a position
for an educator who would be charged
with increasing knowledge and awareness
not only among young women of child
bearing age but also
health care practitioners day care
providers
and indeed all occupations where there's
extensive contact with young children
currently there are discussions about
how to screen will it be the dried blood
spot
will it be some other methodology or
approach
what will the laboratory protocols
consist of what primers by pcr will be
utilized
what cutoffs and controls
how will the information flow through
the notification system
this is something fortunately we've had
some practice on in our studies to date
namely the
study that
in inculcated congenital cmb screening
into the newborn screening program just
like any other screenable disorder
how will the notification system then
flow and what will the follow-up be
will the follow-up consist of the
rawlinson at all criteria analyses as
i've outlined
that include head ultrasonography
laboratory assessments
uh confirmatory virology that's critical
especially in the first 21 days as i've
alluded to
to what extent will this be undertaken
by primary care practitioners
i think one of the bigger challenges may
not be the expertise of primary care
practitioners
throughout minnesota but simply the
availability of those trained adequately
in pediatric audiology
and to some extent radiology the reading
of a newborn
ultrasound
may not be
a test or an evaluation that most
general radiologists are immediately
comfortable with
so a number of working groups are in the
process of being formed and there will
be an active discussion about these
issues
and then interfacing results with other
parts of the minnesota department of
health including
early hearing detection and intervention
or any
neurodevelopmental assessments through
the educational department
and the child
and family health division in the
children and youth with special health
needs section of the mdh will also be
involved in these discussions
so it's going to be complicated
and extensive and a work in progress
but we are excited about it and we're
excited about being the first state in
the united states to
endorse and codify universal screening
and i hope to be able to come back in
the future and
update you uh
about how we are progressing
uh some um
questions that will come up
uh
not only for minnesota but all states um
will
this be endorsed as an addition to the
rest panel
what do we do with the fact that this
still doesn't quite fit the paradigm of
most screenable disorders most of which
have a really
worrisome outcome if they're not
detected well that may not be true for
congenital cmv
uh the ongoing assessment of test
sensitivity is going to continue to be
important
i think we're poised at an 85 to 90
percent sensitivity of dried blood spots
to not let the perfect be the enemy of
the good we can do a lot of good and
help a lot of babies by commencing dried
blood spot screening with our current
methodologies
but these need to be constantly looked
at
and new and better approaches will come
forth in the future and that's been true
for all screenable disorders
in newborn screening
continuing to look at the costs is going
to be critical and then reflecting how
this
will become a part of
what is arguably a changing landscape in
newborn screening
in the advent of the molecular era
uh what what other changes might we
anticipate for other potentially
screenable disorders
that will be an interesting discussion
to participate in in the future as we
move forward
so with that i want to stop uh and
look forward to hearing your questions
uh
this slide is sadly not comprehensive
but um it does capture
at least a lot of the people who've
played critical roles in these
collaborations including
sheila dollard
at the cdc tatiana lanzieri also at the
cdc
mark mccann the director of the newbern
screening program at the state health
department in minnesota and sandra
rosendahl who's been
the genetic counselor and director
of notification
for
newborn screening results kirsten
coverstone in our eddie department
laboratory staff and personnel our state
epidemiologist a pediatrician ruth
linfield who's been very supportive of
these studies
this has been a study not only done in
our university of minnesota healthcare
system but
allina health which is another health
system in minnesota abby sidebottom
who's the director of research there
then people in my own group and
laboratory
shown here in front of the laboratory at
the university of minnesota
and
listed over here on the right side of
the slide
incomplete but at least a
reasonable list of all of the
collaborators and
ancillary staff who've helped
make this work possible
so i think with that um we will move on
into
questions
and i look forward to
hearing your questions and and comments
thank you dr schleich for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
all right let's get started our first
question here asks there are some
commercial platforms available that do
rapid bedside testing of saliva to look
for cmv dna could these be used for
universal congenital cmv screening
yeah i mean it's such an important
question as we see these platforms now
some of them are licensed and marketed
how how should they be used and i think
that
there is a role for these
targeted screening of babies that refer
the new word hearing screen would be one
such role
whether these would be adopt adaptable
to universal screening
i think we'll see i mean this is one of
the deliberations that the minnesota
department of health newborn screening
program will be
discussing as they develop an
implementation plan
i've been an advocate for the dried
blood spot because
i believe it has
a clinically
tenable
sensitivity
and a better specificity that is to say
fewer false positives as one might see
with saliva
my other concern about some of the
platforms that are being marketed for
saliva testing
could be their cost and this could
circle back to health equity issues
uh in the state health department
there's a premium on finding a sensitive
test at a
minimum cost so that it's available to
everybody
and um i think that
the cost of
the bedside
fee for service
marketed platforms um is something we
need to consider moving forward but it's
a great question and uh i again i like
the idea of dried blood spots for the
other reason
being that they're collected anyway i
mean we get them on all newborns and so
it's much less of a cost to the system
because let's face it in the united
states of america the most costly thing
in healthcare
is cost of people's time
and so the additional time required for
nursing staff to
obtain
additional specimens whether it's saliva
or urine
is a concern that needs to be considered
thank you
next question here should a baby that
screams positive for cmv be treated with
anti-viral drugs like valganciclavir
yes well that thank you for that
question i i think that circles back to
some of the comments i was trying to
make about the concern about the overuse
of ganciclovir or valgan cyclovir
let's not forget that this is a drug
that has significant toxicities
um upwards of a third of babies may
develop clinically meaningful
neutropenia on long-term valid
encyclopedia therapy
there's a cost associated with the
frequent laboratory monitoring that's
required for safety
and we
need to be be mindful of that now there
are other drugs in the pipeline
le tamrovir for example has been
licensed for
prophylaxis prophylaxis against cmv
disease and transplant patients
i think that we
um
don't know anything about it really in
infants
but maybe in the future we will see uh
better better um
tests available for
um antiviral drugs uh looking at the
sensitivity of the virus
and um
the need for the reduced need for money
safety monitoring
but right now i think that asymptomatic
babies with congenital cmv should not be
treated with antivirals
great thank you
next question here if a screen comes
back positive from the state laboratory
for cmv can you assume that the baby has
congenital cmv infection or is
additional testing needed if you need
additional tests how soon do they have
to be performed
yes and so as i alluded to i mean yes
you definitely need a confirmatory test
and so in this way it's no different
than hypothyroidism or another
screenable disorder
in the newborn panel and my
recommendation is a urine test that
should be obtained prior to 21 days of
age we we cannot
conclusively make the diagnosis of
congenital cb on a positive screen alone
that's why it's a screening test
thank you next question here what were
the key elements to be able to get
universal screening for congenital cmv
tests approved in minnesota even though
it's not on our usp list
yeah i guess in a word
moms
you know um lobbying in in force and
fashion um
even though i am not much of a expert at
all on social media
um
moms are and they use facebook and other
platforms to
very nicely
mobilize people we had a rally
actually out in front of my lab last
spring
we had legislators attend it was really
just the grassroots lobbying and one of
the things that made it really fun is
that this all happened without
endorsements of
formal thought leader bodies
we we didn't have commercial sponsors it
was all grassroots lobbying by parents
and families it's really democracy in
action
and for those of us who still believe in
democracy in
the united states it was very refreshing
great thank you
we have time for a few more questions
here so this next one asks when talking
about cmv and organ transplantation
i had heard that there is a great
percentage of people that were
unknowingly positive for the cmv
antibody does this say most people have
been exposed to the virus and that they
carry an inactive form of it
yeah so a good question
i would say it means most people are
infected not just exposed they're
infected and i think probably 5 7 of the
world's population
today has cmv infection
most people in all of human history who
have had cmv
probably got it from breastfeeding
mother's milk
and most people are asymptomatic
in
the
hundreds and hundreds of
moms i've interviewed over the years
very very few of women have ever relayed
a specific ailment during their
pregnancy that
made me think of cmv or made me think
that they had a symptomatic cmv
infection mostly in the infections in
pregnancy or asymptomatic
the other important point in that
question and i think the
person who asked it for bringing this up
is cmv infections congenital main
infections actually occur in women who
have long standing immunity
and so that's the great enigma of cmv is
having had infection
does not protect you for life against
re-infection
it's quite fascinating the parallels
with covet 19 where we're having these
same discussions strain variants new
strains emerging women can get
reinfected during pregnancy even if
they're seropositive
so that's why universal screening really
is a
paradigm that should be
exercised for all women irrespective of
the serologic status
it's a debate
worthy of a whole other webinar whether
or not all pregnant women should be
screened for cmv antibodies
but what i've argued is that whether
you're cmv seronegative or sero-positive
you are at risk for either acquiring cmv
primary infection or re-infection during
pregnancy
and transmitting that to um
your baby
and so that's why universal screening of
the newborn i think is really important
now you're less likely to have a
symptomatic or damaged baby
if it's a re-infection
but still 15 or 20 percent of those
babies go on to have hearing loss and so
you can't rely on the presence or
absence of symptoms at birth that's why
universal screening is important
thank you
next question here what are the positive
and negative predictive accuracies of
dbs screening for
ccmv
yeah
great question uh
the positive
predictive value um
and and for that matter the negative
predictive value are both in the 90
percent range
and so we we we didn't see any um
surprises there
um we we
know that the positive predictive value
of any test depends on the prevalence
uh in that population being studied um
you know the reason it was not 99.9
uh is we do have some false positives
with saliva
but the dried blood spot on the other
hand um very few false positives so um i
think the predictive values at least in
our study were quite robust
well it looks like we have time for one
more question here so we'll wrap up with
this one and it asks what specimen type
and testing platform are being used in
ontario for universal screening
yeah so the
um
the ontario platform
is a real-time pcr platform being drawn
down on dried blood spots
and
the
um
primers and
amplification conditions have not
actually been published yet
for those that are interested there will
be a
workshop in canada congenital cmv
meeting the last week of august
and so
for those that would be interested in a
deeper dive
it's a great meeting should be very good
meeting
for general cmv with a lot of
information on screening and i think
we'll hear from the ontario group
there's currently work in progress to
add screening in saskatchewan and a
couple of other provinces
but basically the the platform is
real-time pcr and it's also being done
in conjunction with screening for
connexin
mutations gjb2 the
gene product that's the most common
genetic cause of deafness in north
america uh and so we look forward to
seeing the ontario data published and
comparing notes um with them
i think that'll be extremely valuable
great well thank you again dr schleich
for your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor roche diagnostics
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone goodbye
you